[Musique]
et ce soir nous plongeons dans l'univers
de calhoun poète
actrice chanteuse elle sera l'une des
têtes d'affiché réunionnaise des
francofolies le week-end prochain à
saint pierre après de brillantes études
et de nombreux voyages en europe et en
afrique elle veut aujourd'hui être une
kaffrine du monde jean marc collienne et
laurent figon allons rencontrer
notamment dans une école de saint benoît
pour un projet musical avec des enfants
du quartier de beaulieu à soleil calhoun
anime ce matin un atelier avec elle de
beaulieu à saint benoît areva n'est ce
pas
c'est une des quatre classes qui dans
l'île participent à l'opération
la fabrica chance lancé dans toute la
france par la sacem nous là commence et
créer eux le thème urgence la naissance
d'une petite fille et moi nasa est né ce
matin là la naissance de ma navasa au ma
fille chérie comme on dit ma préférée en
marais
comme ça il ya beaucoup d'enfants
mahorais dans la classe et la chanson va
devenir l'histoire d'une petite fille
qui pleure son papa parti en kwassa
kwassa on pourrait rajouter une petite
mélodie en shimaoré agents refait pas de
domont baba ou un truc que vos parents
vous chante
est-ce que vous avez idée
[Musique]
la petite dame al-din chante alors
timidement une berceuse que calhoun
enregistre sur son téléphone
le morceau i may a au prépaou pour
chanter le monde se pose comme ça nous
sommes bien oui trop beau et c'est top
c'est bon à quoi je sers ayez pas bon du
tout figure au sam querry qu on
réfléchit au travail
il pense à un rôle à jouer dans la
société tout est faux à miner un rôle à
jouer en tant qu artiste de variétés non
non non non mais veut pas moins
ne veut pas être quelqu'un qui irriguent
dans le divertissement mais je ne veux
pas arriver si mes camarades - me écrit
mme hulne a des idées on a envie de
transmettre ses idées là et aussi de
transmettre aussi de pouvoir dire que
ben même si elle est ce qu'à fait nous
sommes bras fusil ou bien bras panon où
fait pas ou écrit aussi nous fait pas
bien que mal rien ne l'est pas la
répudier tiède mouiller nou néna des
choses dont nous tête et voilà où les la
partage ça aussi
l'après midi nous retrouvons câline à la
cité des arts à saint denis pour une
séance de travail avec le producteur et
dj australien antonio rossel ont fait
qu'aujourd'hui
when we were kings cavalaire la chanson
cavalaire fait déjà partie du répertoire
de kalou mais elle travaille aujourd'hui
sur une version plus tn
[Musique]
les gones se fait ben ouais ouais
d'abord oui bah divertir rien demandé
mais peut-être les deux en même temps
parce que peut-être aussi de faire une
musique qui parle au corps c'est aussi
une manière de parler à l'esprit
moncalou commentaire
dans mon cas c'est pas ces gars c'est
pas mal mais c'est qu'à ma musique la
réunion oui c'est la musique la réunion
est aussi la musique du monde il prend
mon héritage plus afro mêlant jaillit un
petit peu avec d'autres univers
techno dance donc c'est une musique la
réunion mais sa musique moderne aussi le
soleil calhoun voudrait qu antonio
travaille aussi sur la chanson des
enfants de beaulieu et elle a apporté la
petite mélodie mahoraise enregistré ce
matin sur son téléphone
luanda la zone bien que la voix du petit
djamaldine peut-être bientôt remixé par
un producteur australien
c'est typiquement ce genre de mélange
que kalou n'affectionne la banane et la
cane moment résume à une partie de mon
enfance ne l'a fait ici parce que le
premier parti c'était à bras fusil après
un petit peu bras panon donc ici c'est
chez madame profil là à bercy à ses
personnages
oui alors madame savoie patricia profil
et directrice de collège et conseillère
régionale
c'est une militante et une mère sévère
mais juste un peu comme ça bien taré
bien commun maman c'est une déesse et la
première personne que la transmettent à
moins beaucoup de maisons et beaucoup de
mes valeurs notamment
sur la fiat et noir sur le fait que
miyama mois comité petit monte néanmoins
comme ça oui ou les commenter le noir où
l'un des hameaux nommément au et oublie
jamais que ça où les oublie jamais ou de
valeurs partout sosa va à côté important
vous c'est d'ailleurs là pourquoi l'un
portant le nom parce que dans l'histoire
de la réunion les les afrodescendants
n'hésite pas place à prendre
et jusqu'à maintenant des
afrodescendants la part prise de place
dans la société réunionnaise est ce que
c'est le moment que là où le talent pour
[Rires]
[Musique]
mac était très mal dans sa peau non
comestibles et ça
dans cette chanson qu'elle a composés
câline pose le mot tabou langues
un vieux mot créole qui désigne le sexe
féminin
on peut tout dire dans la chanson pour
moi il faut tout dire mais avec respect
et surtout aussi peut-être avec humour
aussi des fois pas ce que c'est
c'est super 2018 2018
cent soixante dix ans après l'abolition
de l'esclavagé de pas parler forcément
de l' esclavage des chaînes à mes de
notre vie de tous les jours
il faut tout dire oui avec respect - là
seule la mère des valeurs partagées par
une mère et sa fille a comme l'amour des
vieux maloya ou leur âme à thèmes cités
dans la tête moi l'api sauver